today is going to be a little
interesting because um uh it is
my wife's birthday today and uh well you
know this i did yeah and and so but nice
i don't know why you pretended not i
don't either i know i think i just
you're always very honest
your strength is that you're always
yourself and always honest and you just
did this big fake oh
no i don't know why i did that right so
um you're going to learn a little
something about me which is uh i i have
i have some abilities and skills there
are things i'm good at and then there
are things i'm terrible at okay i'm
terrible at wrapping presents
awful at it and when i wrap a present it
really does look awful and i try and i
try to like measure out the edges and do
it but i i can't do it and i realized my
wife's a stickler she was one of two
kids she just has one sister and a very
small family and so all the presents
were wrapped like even the presents from
quote santa are wrapped on christmas day
my parents were both really busy and
they had six kids they were all born
several hours apart
it was a madhouse and so nothing was
ever wrapped literally it was just like
here's your present and then chuck
something at you
and it was just in however you bought it
at the five and dime that's how it was
that was it you know there was no
wrapping there was no time for that
[ __ ] wait nothing was the bag that
it was
oh my brother neal would just go to the
store and he'd buy you know he'd
basically go to whatever leach mirror
which was the the outlet in the boston
area and he'd get you whatever gift it
was it was in the plastic bag and he'd
whip it at you
and and the thing would spill out there
was no rapping and you know it was oh
wow that's great look at that uh you
know uh half a rubik's cube um
so uh
anyway i sona i i came today
fortunately a couple of the gifts that i
got my wife are wrapped already but i
got her this book and this is going to
come out after her birthday so i can say
it but it's a you know she and i both
love david sedaris so it's david
sedaris's new book this is not an ad or
anything it's just
i bought her um his diaries uh which is
cool it just came out uh carnival of
snackery and i was like oh oh my wife
will love this i'm gonna get this for
her but it's not wrapped and i know that
she's a stickler in my house there'd be
no rapping someone would be like oh
here's your book uh and just chuck it
and this is a hard cover so this would
catch me by on the jaw you know and my
brother luke would have whipped it at me
uh but it needs to be wrapped and so
sona i asked you yeah to bring wrapping
paper and sona is a really good gift
wrapper she's the best she's you're so
good at it yeah i don't know why you're
so good at it but you are the paper what
it's the wrapping paper what do you mean
i mean you have to get the right
wrapping paper if you get [ __ ] wrapping
paper then it sucks okay uh just more
than that you actually so i was gonna
ask you can you wrap this for me
right now you brought the wrapping paper
yeah of course i can can you do this
right now oh yeah and i also
be doing it i've got the scissors i want
to add and i want you to wrap this for
me and now you all know that yeah i did
get my wife a book i got her a couple of
i got her something that i think she's
going to really like and then i get her
you know little things you know little
things here and there and this is a book
it's like butter what's that do you have
the right paper you yeah you go through
it like butter okay it's honestly the
best feeling in the world okay all right
and i'm a mom now and i still think
that's the best but are you gonna do
that are you gonna wrap every gift for
your children of course i'm not gonna
chuck it
seriously nothing was wrapped i've never
i never saw a wrapped gift until i left
home and and and went out in in the
world and then people started handing me
gifts that were covered in paper
and i didn't understand because we grew
up like animals
i'm sorry we really did yeah you did and
uh my wife will gift wrap like a cookie
and it's not even an occasion you know
what i mean at meals you just like i'll
say like hey i'd like some ice for my
drink and there's like a gift wrap cube
of ice that she's put together she's
constantly gift wrapping every single
thing this is a little awkward because
i'm on the table doing this that's all
right
all right no i'm good i have another
question for you because i know you did
a lot of hand-me-downs when people went
shopping for gifts for you did they just
go into their closets
well okay famously uh i say famously but
in our house it was famous my father
would
my father we would give him gifts he'd
be like oh that's so nice but he's very
particular about if he would use the
gift or not and often he'd be like oh
that's very nice and he'd take it
upstairs and he'd put it in his study
and then quite possibly not use it and
then it would hang around his study
all these presents that he never used
and he wouldn't even take them out of
the box like they weren't wrapped but we
could see them uh-huh and so
my brother luke once waited a couple of
christmases and noticed that my father
had never used the clock radio that luke
got him three years earlier and then it
was still in the original packaging in
my father's study over in the corner
with a bunch of other gifts that he had
never even bothered to use
and so my brother luke took it out and
gave it to him again three christmases
later and my father went well this is
fantastic did he not he didn't notice he
didn't know it oh my god my father
didn't notice and he's like isn't this
fantastic oh and look it has am and fm
well look at that isn't that wonderful
and then it went right back upstairs and
went back into the study
and wasn't used did you ever call him
out you don't call my father out on
anything david
i've never had an emotionally honest
conversation with my father in my life
i love my dad i want him to know that
and this is and the only way he'll ever
know is because i'm saying it now on
this podcast and maybe someone will
repeat it to him that's how irish
catholic we are
but uh i can't believe net you are you
are you are i just called you nev my
daughter's name oh no cause you i think
of you as a very immature
no child anywho uh you um that's
beautiful
you did that just while we were here
babbling yeah uh and i was having a
major breakthrough about my dad
a breakthrough were you really having a
breakthrough come on well i mean the
thing about him you know we could never
get the gift that he that's pretty funny
like one time i'd like him to have said
like oh i like this and then you
actually use it but that never happened
no too particular too particular and
finicky about exactly what he wanted but
anyway um why didn't you just ask him
what he wanted because i'm afraid what
he might have told me what was he going
to tell you a better son
exactly a son that didn't disappoint
[Laughter]
wow
that was you know what that was funny
slash
wow wow why i don't know why i put the
sergio leone good the bad and the ugly
yeah soundtrack at the end of that but
um well there you have it sona just
beautifully wrapped this gift for my
wife uh and um by the time you hear this
she will have unwrapped it and said
clearly sona wrapped this